ne rouillent de porte parole du syndicat
national des professionnels infirmiers
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous on
dirait alors le pas sanitaires à
l'hôpital entre war bientôt en vigueur
et pour le conseil constitutionnel
l'application de se passe à l'hôpital
est possible tant que ce dernier à je
cite ne fait pas obstacle à l'accès aux
soins
concrètement ça veut dire quoi bien ça
veut dire que les sages ne sont pas tant
que cela
conseil de l'ordre des médecins avait
alerté sur les problèmes d'accès aux
soins liés à se passer ni thème le
conseil constitutionnel ne l'a pas
entendu et ça pose un vrai problème mon
terme bien de perte de chance des
patients avec un retard au diagnostic ou
au traitement par rapport aux personnes
qui n'auraient pas leur pass sanitaires
et qui serait patients en soins
chroniques ou nouveaux patients en
consultation et ça c'est un vrai souci
pour nous d'autant plus que du coup ça
nous prouve
ça nous prive pardon d'un moment des
changes entre soignants et ses patients
pour justement les convaincre de
l'importance de se vacciner pour eux
mêmes et pour leurs proches
et donc c'est une double peine en
quelque sorte
et puis à côté de ça imaginez la
situation
une famille qui ceux qui se promènent
l'un des membres est victime d'un
accident de la circulation d'un arrêt
cardiaque d'un accident vasculaire
cérébral et il va être pris en urgence
si aucun problème mais par contre les
proches vont être bloqués soit ils
devront donc trouver une une pharmacie
un centre un laboratoire pour faire une
pcr attendent ce résultat avant de
pouvoir rejoindre leurs proches aux
urgences au bloc opératoire
enfin bon c'est contraire à la tradition
d'asile de l'hôpital oui donc selon vous
se passera inévitablement bloquer des
patients dans leur parcours de sens et
même des patients des gens qui vont
aller se faire bâtir
on sait que maintenant on peut ce
verbatim dans les hôpitaux oui c'est un
vrai souci parce que il faut bien
comprendre que du coup la fédération
l'hospitalisation publique a indiqué que
ça allait leur coûter 60 millions
d'euros par mois pour embaucher des
vigiles
on aurait préféré que cet argent soit
utilisé pour embaucher des infirmières
ou des aides-soignantes et est donc bah
à l'entrée de l'hôpital vous avez
aujourd'hui des gardiens qui est parfois
surveille le contenu des sacs dans le
cadre des mesures sécuritaires
demain ils vont contrôler l'identité
contre les le pass sanitaires on va pas
se retrouver dans un hôpital mais dans
une logique de vigie devant une boîte de
nuit enfin bon c'est contraire aux
valeurs que deux portants et puis il y a
également une incidence sociale à se
passe sanitaires il aura forcément moins
de visiteurs on se rappelle les
personnes âgées dans les étals de
revenus premier confinement qui avait
beaucoup parlé du manque de visites de
leurs proches
oui il à la société des soins palliatifs
avait justement alerté par rapport aux
patients en fin de vie également ré qui
risquait de se trouver bloqués dans
cette situation parce que il ya d'une
part des gens qui ne sont pas encore
convaincus de la vaccination et c'est
nous qui à faire le travail pour pour
les convaincre pour ça il faut qu'on les
rencontre
et puis vous en avez également d'autres
qui sont montées en charge vaccinale qui
sont entre la première et la deuxième
dose donc qui ne remplissent pas les
conditions du pass sanitaires donc c'est
un vrai souci
il ya également un autre débat qui selon
vous ans et je me 9,6
ne trompe pas est un faux débat la
vaccination obligatoire des soignants
car selon vous la grande majorité des
soignants est aujourd'hui 26 oui le
santé publique france avait communiqués
le 20 mai dans son bulletin
épidémiologique 64 h 51 que 91% des
professionnels de santé étaient vaccinés
les chiffres utilisés par le
gouvernement ces derniers jours c'était
simplement les chiffres santé au travail
des hôpitaux qui ne prenait en compte
que les soignants qui s'étaient fait
vacciner par la médecine du travail de
l'hôpital ou dans un centre de
vaccination rattaché à l'hôpital n'est
pas tous ceux qui s'étaient vacciner en
ville en particulier quand il
intervenait eux-mêmes dans des centres
de vaccination
en tant qu'opérateur de la vaccination
puis il ya aussi toute la période où il
manquait des doses un peu partout et
chacun allait se vacciner là où il
pouvait dans les centres qui étaient
disponibles
donc c'est un mauvais procès qui a été
fait aux soignants la matière et on paye
un peu choqués nous soignants de se
retrouver comme bouc émissaire de cette
histoire une décision du conseil
constitutionnel qui est également
particulièrement inquiétante
c'est par rapport au fait de ne plus
être isolés
le principe de ces tests est isolé déjà
avant c'était assez choquant que la
possibilité d'avoir deux heures de
sorties dans le cadre d'une quarantaine
obligatoires c'était vraiment lui une
originalité française
mais la dir bon on va vous testez vous
est positif mais vous faites ce que vous
voulez c'est pas notre problème c'est
particulièrement interpellant parce que
le principe d'isolement c'est pour ne
pas contaminer les autres avec un
variant comme le variant indien c'est
particulièrement indispensable et donc
c'est une aberration sanitaire qu'a
prise la le conseil constitutionnel
thierry amouroux merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
porte parole du syndicat menace
des professionnels infirmiers mercier